[Music]
[Music]
what's happening you're listening to the
handsome Rambla episode 7 we're in
Australia yeah
Melbourne Sydney when Sydney Australia
I'm Hannibal Buress
Tony trim kadai Mike al Jackson what up
son
in Australia kickin it man
we good times just got in it's exciting
it's your first time I'll show you out
very first so yes I some bucket-list
[ __ ] man it's like yeah I was trying to
be cool about it but like you can't do
cool [ __ ] man this is dope man I'm
excited so far it's so far away it's
only first time in Australia first time
in Australia yeah man this is nice this
is my I've been in a couple times before
but it's my first time as a headlining
touring act
I played the Melbourne Festival two
years no excuse me five years ago and it
was me Moshe kasher and Tom Segura were
on shows together and whatever happened
to those guys Tom's a DJ no Tommy's a DJ
dad mouths and again and so we were on
these shows for about two weeks where we
each did 15 20 minutes and it was called
headliners and I was my first time out
here anyway it was cool and spent two
weeks
Jenica and then came back to following
year played the Sydney Festival and went
to Sydney and Brisbane and it's a fun
time out here it's a different vibe out
here I don't know if it's because we're
visitors no it's a different vibe it's
an energy people are welcoming despite
what's happening politically in our
country people are still kind of chill
what do you attribute that to because I
definitely feel it too if yeah if I go
into him I go just as you go somewhere
different like it's different here but I
don't feel that in certain countries
like I feel it's a different vibe here I
don't know man is maybe it's just
because of me I don't know there's a lot
of there's a lot of hypotheses cc's
hypotheses
you could have about it maybe it's the
isolation
this is far away yeah it's so far away
and so if you come this far and you net
acting like a [ __ ]
and people say hey welcome yeah man it's
uh it's nice over here I love enjoy so
is very far but it's good I'm excited we
got the first show tonight in Sydney
sold out any more theater sold out 1600
seats
congratulations man on an island in the
middle of nowhere his stuff is a little
different here
alien sense of humor is pretty awesome
cuz I was a friend of mine put me on
Clair put me on to this movie called the
castle I think I've ever seen this no
never lair it's like some Australian
humors crazy what just what is the humor
is it over-the-top was something it's
like real dry and it's like the movie
was about just this like family guy and
he's got he's got some goofy as kids and
he lives real simple next to an airport
but it's all like the simple little
nuances of goofy [ __ ] that he does every
day that just makes it it's hard to
explain these guys yeah but it's like is
it on Netflix I'm not sure you illegally
downloaded it I'd say it I played that
[ __ ] I plead the fifth on that say that
[ __ ] that's my I don't know have you
been around when uh that's my new thing
I'm trying to force this part of my raps
trying to make the laughs rhyme with the
d'bari you were thinking about doing
that but I've known ya I've been leaning
into it lately I've been locked in I've
got very comfortable having a
Podcast at first it seemed like a duty
and now I need to do it so I don't get
these bars off I've ever started in
Austin I'm trying I'm trying to get in
you know
the podcast is freeform I'm able to get
my getting my bars off and it's been
it's been it's been a good time man you
know the humor here um I did this show
the project to promote that's why I got
in before y'all to do some press in
Melbourne this show the project it's a I
never seen it cuz it's Australian TV but
a lot of people watch it apparently and
it's a good promotional opportunity so I
have to sign them from that on Instagram
by the way yeah and we're you know so
the show I get there early so I can
watch the whole show it starts off opens
up with serious news these people got
murdered were you like oh then it goes
into it goes to the panelist is Florida
one of them's comedian another guy's a
serious journalist sort of but funny
he seems you know the he seem like he's
on point and it's a couple other feel
much about them but it's formed and in
it talking about stuff and laughing
right after that without even addressing
that murder package that murder video
package that they showed at the
beginning and then he goes in to take
some investigative journalism stuff then
it was a where are they now segment
about these famous Australian television
actors and it was something else and
then a cuts a interview with his
comedian Tim mentioned he's really for
they cut so an interview with him and
then it's a couple other things I mean
it was me at the end and so I was uh you
know trying to plan how I want to
approach this because I'm thinking they
told me the question guy told me the
questions before and there's one of
those things I'm looking at man I can't
I've been I've done these type of
interviews before with I don't know
these people and they don't know my vibe
did it's not gone you know right it's
now gonna work as a and you know some
you know
some basketball players don't mesh well
together even if they good at what they
do they might have bad team chemistry
you know Rondo is a good player didn't
work smoothly for him in Dallas doesn't
mean he's not good and so I'm gonna have
to I just was backstage why doesn't just
planning and so I'm just going to be a
weirdo and take over if i'ma have to to
get my agenda across which is just
trying to sell tickets and I can't let
cuz I've done it where I'll let done
that type of show up when I swallowed up
but you end up doing a bland interview
because you just let them control it but
y'all on this show all the time
I'm on here for five minutes this year
this maybe every this might be my only
five minutes ever on this television
show and most I probably I mean if I
come back to Australia at the soonest
it'll be probably two years from now so
I gotta make this happen and so walk it
into the when we were walking up to the
villa we it was his book on the ground
my first numbers and the PA or a
producer he was meeting us outside it
looked like this woman had dropped it
cuz she had a stroller with a baby and a
toddler and the book was fresh and clean
and so it looked like she dropped it so
he runs up grabs the book off the ground
miss this is your book and she kind of
waves him off like a homeless dude no I
still think it was her book anyway it
just look like that but whatever and so
I grabbed a book I thought take it and
then I don't know what I'm gonna do to
do with this but I'll take it
and we're about to walk in the building
five seconds after I get the book is
these guys outside with a camera animal
purse can we take a picture yeah we
could take a prison you gotta hold this
book though never felt so good immediate
validation from grabbing an object off
of the ground
never felt amazing oh man yeah dude hose
up the book and then and then we get
upstairs an agreement I'm watching the
you know first half-hour Chozen and like
you know what I'm just gon bring this
book out neck like it's my book let's
just read it so they'd get out some
questions I'm kidding around and I say
I'm really hitting promote my book put a
book out my first numbers it was from
the Australian Football League AFL and
just had different objects one o'clock
two footballs three this for this and I
just counted through each page they was
so weirded out but I was just powering
through and we'll just do something
weird and just have fun versus oh it's
so I've went through the whole thing and
then at the end said oh hey we got part
2 coming up so 6230 felt great and then
but then one of the journalists trying
to bring the interview back straight
right after that whole weird massive
she's it oh so you're in a Baywatch
movie that was that you ever expect that
like that's you're not gonna try to roll
with stuff at all just gonna bring it to
Baywatch that comes out six months from
now
cool I said more right now in this
interview than I did in the Baywatch
movie want to talk about that it's a
weird thing
I think comics because we can not only
do we interact with each other when you
kind of gotta be on your feet at all
times but like if you're just a
journalist like somebody that's sharp
and quick and can probably rip you up I
think that you need to try and keep that
interview in your bumper lane yeah you
know bowling like you're like we need to
keep it about Baywatch and he's from
Chicago and how did he feel about you
know broad city like is because if she
starts trying to follow you wherever you
go and like it was walking there I said
any you know I just should have kept on
I mean it would have been funny about
this like no
enough about Bey time now to hear about
Baywatch leaned in let's talk about this
book I don't even know if y'all was
feeling what I was going through right
here sort of ran through the book like
let's talk about 16 through 30 I think
was 16 he's gonna be 16 X in seventeen
shelves and 18 glasses and 19 sunglasses
should've leaned in hindsight 2020 dude
that's what's up though the fact that
you went through the first 15 don't
don't show yourself that's pretty
amazing cuz I might have failed I'd be
like lip and you if you wore out your
phone download the live out press that
button in the cars there right in a snap
hop in the back grab the aux cord put on
songs vibe out drunk hanging in the back
don't have to drive drunk five star
rating cuz he's not a real Punk hanging
in a lift all the drivers are saved you
don't even have to worry about get la la
la a lot of left live live live
literally of death Liv Liv Liv Liv Liv
Liv Liv Liv right now lyft is offering
our listeners a special deal get three
free rise up to ten dollars each that's
up to a $30 value when you enter promo
code handsome Rambler handsome rambling
just download the free lift up to date
and enter promo code handsome Rambler in
the payment section you start with three
free rise up to technologies that's up
to a $30 value promote handsome Rambler
has a rambling lift lift lift lift lift
lift lift your spirits lift your feet
and put them in the car lift your body
go anywhere bizarre lifts lift yourself
like Joel Osteen
left naturebox makes snacks that
actually taste great and are better for
you created with high quality
ingredients that are free from
artificial colors flavors or sweeteners
so you can feel great about snacking go
to nature box comm and check out that
snack catalogue there are over 100
snacks to choose from and they're
constantly adding delicious new snacks
choose the snacks you want and they'll
deliver them right to your door their
new snacks every month and if you ever
try snack you don't like nature box will
replace it for free and right now you'll
save even more nature box is offering a
handsome Rambler fans 50% off your first
order
when you go to naturebox.com/tyler
that's nature box.com
Rambler nature box calm
[Music]
[Music]
I was sooo I was jet-lagged but still
wit cuz I landed at 9:30 that morning
and my first piece of press I did radio
12:30 so I was a little loopy out you
know had a I took a motor for Neil to
get going but then they asked me about
the jet lag on the show and I jokingly
said oh I took five adderall's and then
blogs in Australia picked it up Oh
Hannibal Buress takes adderall five out
of Rosen do you know what five
adderall's is at the at ten milligram up
at the minimum 50 Mill o'clock do you
know do you know my ATV likes it with my
energy wouldn't be like of someone
calmly reading through children's book
one through 15 on live television it
wouldn't be one page so much you know
what I think about man is like you think
about this mate you fly across country
cart across country across the world I
meet up with you Tony meet up we figure
it out lots of travel logistics and [ __ ]
like do you ever think about like what
it must have been like to have to get
Rick James on a flight and get him
somewhere to rest get him back and find
him after the show yeah into it I mean
just look have you thought about like
what it was like to get James Brown like
yeah right wrangle him you know yeah
they had to do in private like but I
mean I'm sure you would just take off at
some point it's just like you don't
worry yeah what is it what are they
disappeared soon and it's the 80s what
you gonna do call him yeah he's just in
Memphis somewheres like we joke around
while taking a drug that keeps you
focused on your job I'm like I got a
homie that's a tour battery
I'm not gonna name any names but he
manages a band that's pretty big and
they're a younger band and he's just say
Club Nouveau he said and I said it's
like bait he's like half of the half of
the job is just babysit and making sure
[ __ ] get on the bus at the
right time don't do too much drugs and
stay safe
yeah you know they have a tour manager
for us for this one and I was like dude
as cool as hell
shine as cool as hell but I want this
thing for what we good yeah yeah is this
flying I mean when we had we had the
tour manager when we did the bus run a
couple years ago and that was it took
some you got to coordinate the bus and
you know merchandise it was a lot of
other moving parts but here we go into a
couple different cities we go to airport
or remember that weird as security pact
that followed us around in South Africa
oh yeah I felt so bad for those guys
well I guess it goes down in South
Africa so yeah kidnapper this yeah well
they have like three dudes that was just
basically cooped up with us it was like
the driver is one big really big dude
and there's a kind of internist internee
kind of kid yeah but they would like
being a lobby waiting for us and then we
go to the club to like 5:00 in the
morning they'd be outside waiting for is
really like an hour to two a night like
we ruin their life did that casino where
they gave us each security
I forgot what casino was the one where
the what's wrong with your hands and
casino yeah okay is that Washington
have we ever told that story that was
well that's what all right Tony tell the
story not so Vic I'm just saying this
before talk is that what I said to
somebody for see it's already pointing
them you know what's wrong with your
head
it's actually very simple we got we went
in that night well what was that that
was uh that weird Cassini it was a
casino where they gave my lip to
littlest that's exactly what it is that
was tool Allah yeah we wait I always
notice cities just cuz I always look
back at my records to see if somebody
cheated me so I'm like tulip May 20th
2015 wedding money like forget it
whatever and then you decided to go back
downstairs and start gambling whatever
so you were you were out and about oh
yeah and then the next morning we had to
get you had to get to the jet and it was
like it wasn't one of them just miss the
flight things I was like no I gotta wake
this guy I'm knocking knocking yeah
everything no answer and I know you're
in there yeah so I get I get security to
open the door and then I walk in the
room and you have all your clothes on
you just facedown with your feet still
oh yeah you know I'm able to say yeah
I'm able to sleep in all types of
situations for everybody at home it's
like that thing that's on your desk
where the bird dips into the water yeah
except the bird never stood back I was
ready to go - I was like Hannibal wake
up wake up wake up you finally wake up
you pop up and you're looking at me and
the first thing you say is all right man
what's wrong with your hands oh you used
with your hair I remember it is your
hands were shaking yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's you wake up as we were getting to
that point where was like weak we were
running out of window in terms of time
to leave yeah and I go because you were
like what do you want to do he's not
answering the phone and I was like we
gotta just key in there you go dude I
want to go in there he might be dead
we couldn't get you that's like if
you're that worried we need to key into
the door tell you just don't wait it out
I'm like we need to get in here I don't
want to see my side of the story so I
had I'm not gonna get into the we got
the details of that but he was you know
I had met a friend I met a new friend on
a casino floor for that night and we
went upstairs and put our parts on each
other's parts and then she left and I
was still full of energy and I went down
to the casino floor
and I went to the roulette table and
that was just this woman that was I
don't even play roulette like that but I
don't know if they were had a craps or
if but I just you know just hang out and
grab a drink a good place and so she was
getting crushed or whatever she was just
getting destroyed and she was just
talking about I think I was playing on
the outside I'll play black and red I
don't play on played numbers all in
roulette one cuz [ __ ] you're one out of
35 watts give me give me the
half-and-half sand I'll play that note
and then I hope that a double zero
doesn't happen so she just busts out and
then she started talking about all you
know if I play this and this oh you you
know I know how to get back so I was
just in a good mood and you know I was
relaxed empty ball and I said you know
what I'll stake you and I eat the game
of 50 or $100 to gamble with there's no
that gave her some chips and then and
then she just got excited she kind of
lit up and then she started uh she
started so I was like you know 50 so so
she started gambling with that fit they
started getting up and [ __ ] you know
damn okay [ __ ] helped her bounce back
and then she lost all that [ __ ] again
[Laughter]
and in a subversion of other guys let's
go up to the room and talk about it I
don't know is I bring up to the room
this is bad I mean she was just yeah it
was she had a lot of other stuff going
on when we were upstairs talking in the
room and then she's talking about family
and she like started crying his [ __ ] all
this with a different weight and I
wanted it to go hmm and we were drinking
and I think I had a bottle upstairs we
was drinking and whisky and then she
started crying and eventually she left
and then I passed out cuz I think we
were up into the daylight and so that's
why you know I uh okay that's why you
found me facedown without my clothes on
I was on a casino floor connecting with
people and yeah you have been on an
emotional roller coaster
there's no old dude in your life as she
coming up that like takes you aside and
be like at some point in your male life
a girl's gonna start crying on you and
you're gonna be like I don't know what
to do were like it's always when you're
like it like go a kiss and you're like
alright touching you be like okay he's
going down yeah and then you just hear
yeah she was definitely degenerate
gambler and it takes over her [ __ ] in a
way where is this different I I don't
know I care but I don't let it take off
i straight-up be a disease I've seen it
ruin family members that way oh it's so
real money like yeah yeah you know how
they have my double use I've had my
losses but it's never consuming is never
will change
I'll never won't be able to do something
like I took a L
that I will do something me because I
again will just in my mind to make up
well oh man I gambled that's uh I lost I
guess I'm playing Billings Montana next
month Rock Arkansas shout out to any
city that's get added on last minute
because the [ __ ] Patriots didn't
cover that's a weird thing gambling my
my best friend there's eight years of
recovering with gambling and it
destroyed his life he said because he
was like when I'm dudes he'd be up you
know be college basketball tourney so 32
games going so you say into the first
round you up 32 G's and the second round
you down 17 and you know guys coming to
collect like real dudes yeah are coming
for that dough this ain't no they know
ray Donovan yes is your life there's a
dude on the way to your house and you
coming up 19 G short I can't I just
can't deal with anxiety even the anxiety
of winning as much as I love the rush
I'm just like yeah and then people ask
me what's wrong with your hands that's
how you could tell somebody's a real
compulsive gambling is that winning and
losing feels exactly the same yeah you
know I I got an offer to host the AVN
Awards yeah the porn Awards yes you're
gonna offer before to do that they just
kind of was talking about it and then
they sent an official offer because I
went to him last this year last minute
just decided I just saw that they were
going I saw somebody my friend Igor
may be taking pictures or we were
texting him I'm at the point of words
and I happened to be in LA yeah yeah you
know what gotta go check out the foreign
awards and it was
it was crazy the porn Awards uh is weird
man hosted it the year you went I forgot
her name she's a newer comedian um it
was a lot of it was it was fun
just matches being in a hotel just not
just the words themselves but the you
know the day before the porn parties it
was a lot of those girls know me and
[ __ ] yeah it's a little intimidating
yeah cuz I think I had I mean I'm
certain I had a shot with some of them
but I didn't I just didn't go for it cuz
I said I want to be what does it feel
like meeting somebody that you've
dragged off to before uh you know is
that's with the image I try to play it
cool I try to play it cool you know Dana
dearmond yeah I met her she's cool she's
cool she comes to comedy shows and [ __ ]
and and I met her several times I just
play a cold man and just you know I
don't even we don't even I don't even
talk about her work I just break oh you
uh you ever watch Wilfred no I mean yeah
I don't know a lot of times this is what
I would do this is what I'll do if I
reveal Twitter and then I was
occasionally every day it doesn't happen
that often but you know it's been a
let's say ten times over my Twitter
where a porn star would tweet me hardly
funny and sweet me and then look and
I'll just see that xxx and they handle
did not google them and look at their
porn and jackoff just cuz I was they
just tweeted me like let me see what our
work is about yeah but it was some it
was a Sarah J was sitting right behind
oh yeah no fair J yeah it was I was
intimidated man cuz I just didn't want
to be you know fodder for their porn
podcast you know what comedian finishes
very fast and falls asleep just how and
I would think that a porn star would
know like when they're [ __ ] with a
regular dude like to lower the bar yeah
when you watch browsers and stuff I'm
like these urges
plates that you happen to be having sex
now the men and women having sex and
that is professional sex work yeah like
they're putting on a show that has
nothing no human I mean that bro that's
not even sex really yeah I'm saying like
they're probably taking breaks wiping
each other maybe like they are going
nuts yeah I'm up
yeah I didn't know I kept it I kept a
regular that we could but he was it was
I was in it was just funny seeing Awards
best I know
and the award for best interracial scene
goes to yeah yeah it was a but I don't I
don't think I'm gonna host it to who's
the new black they do it on the scene
since Lexington student lexington steele
did he retire I don't know it's only six
black dudes they flourish Wesley Pipes
Byron long yeah and then it was a who
was the dude that was rapid
it was mr. Marcus but if the market mr.
marquales he's out of the game no rapper
I think half of them rap it was like the
first few I knew if you're a black do
porn star of course you rap definitely
you got so much fodder so much so much
when you say I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] but
that's real people yeah I believe them
you hear you hear the conviction in his
voice no it was the dude that Brian
pumper Brian pumper yeah he was he was
rapping all right so you're not gonna do
the you I think you should you're not
gonna do why is the offer now good or
you just don't want to put yourself out
there like this offer is great so do it
everything ain't about money and [ __ ]
all the time but that'll be it was some
good material it'll be it'll you know
what I'm saying you gotta make the best
out oh that's that's a that's an honor
to be good but yeah the great comics
have done that that's not even like you
know why why if I do the porn Awards am
I gonna be a secret life of pants for
ah point okay okay all right all right
all right if I do the porn Awards yeah
plus you're playing Superman's coach so
that's probably not a good look for this
I don't know buddy it is Parsa to do
that I just don't think it's uh but me
but another part of me wonders if it's
kind of saying [ __ ] that I'll do this
and I also do this I will voice dogs and
children's movie also I'll get up and do
a [ __ ] sketch about animals with some
porno woman I mean are they think about
people or comics who ever do raunchy or
edgy stuff but also their children's
stuff hmm it's not that me as far as
specially as far as host didn't comics
ever done that it's been like I know
Robert Schimmel did it Chimel the tale I
think probably Norton Florentine maybe
baby I'm just gonna be no no that I mean
you know I might be overtaking it I
might well I don't think so I think it's
something to talk with your people about
because that's a very raw they were even
when it was just in discussion before
they sent an official off of months and
months ago my agent please don't
[Music]
but this week the Phoenix Sun sucks oh
that [ __ ] was real cheap but I wouldn't
have known unless I didn't have seen
game hey hey
they were playing the heat not even
playing the Timberwolves and I had a bet
they covered that [ __ ] Timberwolves
would the starting point guard is Chris
Dunn he was picked number five Thibodeau
is the coach he's violent he's the coach
for the Bulls been the cutter and he was
like cold sea geek experience in life
see he got my credit card information
and they chill with it I deal with it
secant got me all filled with him what I
don't still did it
what go to the dentist huh and I go in I
get it
what Wow fart yeah oh my see geek man
y'all know what it is tickets and stuff
too anything best price tickets is easy
it's smooth you can get mobile tickets
on there it's great to get your $20
rebate on tickets download the free
SeatGeek app go to the Settings tab
click add a promo code
it's a promo code Rambler Rambler
Rambler Rambler ckick will send you $20
after you've made your first ticket
purchase download the free CT cap it's a
promo code Rambler Rambler rrrr a AAA
BBB bler lram ble our Rabb Allah
fart fart
[Music]
but it's interesting just cuz you know I
am into doing stuff for the experience
and that's a different experience now a
lot of things it's a thing that not a
lot of people get offered and I do talk
about porn
I do enjoy pornography although I
haven't watched porn in a few weeks
actually non porn face for a while now
you know it's weird now are you are you
protesting [ __ ] eliezer just habit
you know
you know sometimes you go through
experiments like how long can I go on
it's not even it hasn't even been a
conscious thing where well [ __ ] I need
to stop it and then I need to you know I
need to rewire my brain it's just I
haven't been watching it a lot maybe
what does that mean am i happier
am I more relaxed and one more chill at
Chicago taking the point I got my own
place in Chicago with my own Wi-Fi and I
know and I'm there by myself all the
time and I got tables couches and beds
and that [ __ ] and I never pulled up
pouring her up in my place
okay make Australia great I don't think
these are congratulations or what the
[ __ ] I think it's just so I think it's
just all right all right I wasn't
listening TED talks when I get in the
shower yeah you know yeah always man you
can knock out like tear tear off it
sounds like just 10 minutes with 17
minutes 17 min yeah that's a good time
to like let you know that I get up Xiao
Yue knows that now listen to this one it
was like this dude was like why I
stopped watching porn and some of that
yeah yeah it was interesting I felt his
points you know he was saying that it
decreases your sex your sensuality like
instead of just like hardcore like
dang [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] he's like
you never see like people like being
sensual with their hands and stuff like
that yeah and I kind of like that I
agree with that I mean I don't know I
would guarantee I would say that there's
a lot of couple that probably watch porn
- get off - with it to each other I
think it's like a tool like anything
else like as long as you don't overdo it
I don't think you need a completely cut
off form because have you guys tried to
masturbate just using your memory that
shit's here no it's impossible I know I
can't do that at all eating that's
impossible
what no as a kid I used to be able to
beautiful but now that's the most
pathetic like image like some guy would
have pants around his ankles and a
magazine in front of them and just jag
into it that's how you know this picture
it's just mental illness or just weird
fetishes because you talk about in New
York with dudes jagan off on the train
what you jagan on new york with all that
distraction all that noise
you're a would have focused I don't know
to climax what all that noise
all of that next stop yeah 49th Street
you telling me you can't ran you can
plug and come to transfer to the 2:00
and 3:00 train doors closing what you
can do is close it you can still come
and it's somebody Oh scuse me ladies and
gentlemen I'm Mattie I'm here for my
basketball team just here our
performance real quick and you can steal
oh you can come to a goddamn mariachi
bed what about flashes like what what is
going through their mind like what what
do you get out of just opening your
trenchcoat be like look at my [ __ ]
it's perversions like I think something
that just seemed innocent usually they
do it towards kids or women or something
something that's like put on the
pedestals away there you know
like I'm sure Matt psyche like what do
you know people like you know I mean I
don't I don't act on it doesn't make me
want to jag off right there yeah but
something it does turn me on as if if a
woman is sitting in a chair with her
legs crossed and she got on heels or
sort of flats or something and she let
the heel of a shoe dangle off her foot a
little bit yeah something about that I'm
not gonna jag off in public but I will
crack my knuckles like that the
beginning of her undress yeah her going
from her professional self to her more
because I got a homey sign of like
straight up feet fat not like feet
fetish like like more like I have a
homey unnamed that's like can you please
take off your shoes so I can touch your
feet kind of yeah like foot fetish yeah
and I think feet fetishes are weird I
don't quite get it they're the most
common ones though I don't I don't have
a fee fetish but I remember in my
probably 20s being disgusted by feeling
ill girls feet and now I'll happily give
a girl a foot massage what about a foot
job though a foot job after next now I
if I want too much foot action I have
had a woman kind of graze my dick with
her foot you know that's cool but it was
like doesn't that make that the focus of
the night
you know across the table or something
and in y'all that is fancy you know
touch a such a dick with her foot that's
cool but you know let's not get too
heavy and and all of them understand it
that that's not what was there for the
surprise this feat rather than like
women's hair I feel like I'm Way more
into a women woman's hair like you know
I'm saying like in terms of I like all
the different kinds I like I like black
hair like traditional black hair I like
dreads I like long blonde hair I like
that curly kind of mary-jane from
half-baked kind of hair like I'm in the
hair but it's not sexual but I'm like I
think that that's the thing that mostly
besides breasts obviously distinguished
men and women is like their hair so I'm
so surprised so many more dudes don't
have like man I got a redhead fetish I
came to come unless she's a red like but
you rarely hear that if ever
but you feed it just like I don't know
is it feet is this this thing you know
like II there's there's something to say
about a woman who has well-kept feet
because if the feets is busted
that's a deal-breaker could you can't
well you see a girl wearing like some
open-toed shoes and the feets are busted
you can't that's terrible so there is
something about because you know some
yeah yeah well-kept feet cuz that says a
lot about everything else the way
everything else is kept you know I'm
saying but other than that that doesn't
really go beyond anything but yeah feet
could be sexy but it's just weird when
guys are like my feet yeah yeah
sometimes when I'm feeling especially
coordinated during sex and in kind of a
good zone hitting it and I got a legs up
in there and it sometimes besides her
feet while I'm [ __ ] her wow that's
very you're very over always always try
to think of something extra I could do
sometimes if I'm if I'm into it I'm
feeling I always try to custom writers
try to I do something a little extra
will do should so I don't come
have we hold their feet like what this
bone this one is the fibula I got like
I'm like an old veteran pitcher you know
it's like my fastball is gone but I got
like a spit ball I've been cheating
stealing I couldn't [ __ ] like I'll stop
do you ever stop for just you blaming on
something I grew up out the counter grip
and then like everything I just need
like seven seconds of air dick time and
then three minutes then come back yeah
you know what works for me is I think of
a bad smell when I think it smell always
kills me I think of a bad smell whatever
it might be it might be twenty minutes
it might be too wanted for us that night
is what's gonna happen if you make
Australia - do you like even a dress are
you just like hey was it with this - do
you even address it or you just pay uh
when you have to compliment their grief
a good sometime I mean a lot of times
they end up you know getting way more
into each other than me anyways because
as far as looks go always start so yeah
you know okay I'll try to you know
bounce back if I can if I've been
hydrating well that week my bounce back
time is a little is a little decent but
yeah that's - disappointed - is
you don't want to do that but yeah this
is what the Lord nobody ever brings the
Lord into that this is what the Lord
wanted the Lord did not want you all to
get dick down tonight I just wanted you
to get poked a little bit and for me to
get sleepy now let's watch Wilfred and
go to bed that leads me to a question
real quick yeah do you count it as a
threesome if the girls don't interact
yeah yeah there's three in the sack it's
a three years three yeah if it's a
little weird when they don't touch it
although but if this is what you all if
this is what we're doing then job bless
ya three in a sector's naked sexual
activities are going on that's a
threesome is it's a foursome person you
should be talking about middle school
[Laughter]
unhappy people let's start a softball
team
so uh later y'all Sydney we out here
even though isn't that this is that live
but that's where we are right now Sydney
Melbourne Brisbane Perth we out here and
some Rambla al Jackson Sony trim all
right oh that was a fun one kicking off
our Australia podcast run
we got good episodes coming out with
napalm fights coyote legendary comedian
frankly exact Eric Andre it's been a
good run so check out those episodes
subscribe share review all that stuff
handsome rambling nope no I look fine
alright later hello I'm John Lennon I'm
simply having a wonderful Christmas time
with all my new elf much just look at
what it will have added to this store
this year make your friends jealous guys
with a brand new Earwolf activity book
go out a magical mystery tour in your
hello from the magic tavern t-shirt
shake it up baby with the longest
shortest time baby onesie and this gear
from comedy bang bang how did this get
made and so much more
imagine all the deals go to store dot
Earwolf dot-com today and use the promo
code ho-ho to get 15% off your purchase
if your order by December 10th pick up a
great gift for the podcast fan in your
life this holiday season drums
this has been an ear wolf production
executive produced by Scott Aukerman and
Chris Bannon for more information and
content visit Earwolf dot-com